what this event is what it means and how
you actually go about selecting the
honoree they really care about me hi
Trina cargo who runs the US Ireland
Alliance is sort of the mastermind of
all of this and I think her vision board
is always bring a combination of like
the sort of most interesting artists
from the US and Ireland together and to
look for synergies for the two countries
to do great you know interesting
projects together and it's always fun
because if there's great live music and
there's always you know some comedians
and that's it's just a fun warm night
and lots of Guinness which is always
yeah everyone's talking about how
relaxed and fun of it I gotta ask you
you just wrapped episode 9 that photo
made me emotional just looking at it can
you talk about that moment on set wrap
him up film it was actually a pretty
emotional thing but the cast and crew
just did an unbelievable job and I just
cannot wait to see what because you know
the last gen I people reacted to it how
they did did that change the way that
you approached episode 9 and all did
which did the way that you approach
episode 9 was that affected by the way
that people reacted to the last Jedi at
all no I think that every movie is its
own movie and obviously this is a
trilogy we brought to that movie all the
the passion and hard work that we would
have no matter what so I think you know
I think the story speaks for itself I
really truly can't wait to see it can I
just ask you about directing Billy Dee
Williams as Lando and what that was like
for you because I know you're a big fan
but we get to see him as Lando again I'd
met him much before and he was such a
sweet guy but I got to tell you I have
such unbelievable respect for him we had
we had a great time and he was he was
wonderful I mean everyone on set had
this he just had this aura around him
he's really an incredible man and black
Joe you give me kind of like maybe a
word or some me we're gonna feel going
out of this movie because we've seen you
know two other Star Wars trilogies come
to a close how does this stack up
compared to you know Sith and Jedi
you have to determine that you know
yourself but I uh well III really can't
make me to see it and there are there
are a lot of words that we all hope that
you feel and and and obviously the the
biggest most important when I think is
satisfied fans are just clamoring for
that title can you give us any kind of
hint of when we're getting it no but
listen but it's really fun talking to
you though
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]